20:16 has already brought us lots of
excellent games to enjoy so many that is
tough to narrow down the absolute best
of the bunch nevertheless we've got
something for every kind of gamer when
it comes to the best games of the year
so far
here's loopers top 7 video games the
first half of 2016
Dark Souls 3 Dark Souls 3 is all about
dungeon crawling fighting difficult
enemies and dying a lot when you think
you've mastered your character all it
takes is one box dodge to totally wreck
you the world of Dark Souls 3 is
absolutely gorgeous with plenty of Lord
to discover assuming you don't throw
your controller out the window first
XCOM to finding out that humans lost the
war against the aliens who invaded
during the first game is a bit of a
bummer but this turn-based tactics game
is filled with unpredictable missions
that'll test your fortitude just don't
get too attached to your squad because
they're probably gonna die sneaking onto
the battlefield to fight ruthless aliens
is always a fun nail-biting experience
and if you're lucky you might even
survive the witness nobody would have
expected a 3d puzzler to do so well on
an era defined by Halo and Call of Duty
but fans of the classic missed games
will enjoy the witness which exercises
your brain rather than your reflexes
gamers explore an open-world island
filled with unconventional
thought-provoking puzzles the witness
puts you in a world that will inspire
plenty of Eureka moments and actually
reaching its true ending puts your wits
and creativity to the test Fire Emblem
fates Fire Emblem fates birthright
conquest and revelation are all slightly
different versions of the same game but
they all offer some of the best RPG
experiences of a year so far the series
rock-paper-scissors approach to combat
is streamlined here enough to make
things captivating and engaging even for
serious vets the plot between the three
versions of the game relies heavily on
politics and scheming and depending on
which version of the game you get the
story events and the unit classes you'll
have access to will be drastically
different play all of them hyper light
drifter hyper light drifter might be one
of the best games of the year the
vibrant colors make hyper light drifter
stand out while its controls in its
combat system are fantastic
exploring never gets boring or
repetitive and as you play you learn
more about the world of its dangers
soon you'll be completely sucked in and
never want to leave uncharted for a
thief's end the fourth game in the
Uncharted series is already a modern
classic after enjoying monumental
success with the first three
installments developer Naughty Dog rose
to the challenge and topped themselves
uncharted 4 exceeded expectations and in
the series in a high note thanks with
great storytelling and amazingly
gorgeous visuals in gameplay
uncharted 4 is a must buy for all ps4
owners overwatch what can we say about
blizzards team-based shooter overwatch
that hasn't been said a thousand times
already that it managed to breathe new
life into a tire John rrah that has got
something to offer for every type of
player that it's cast of colorful
characters tight controls and fantastic
visuals all contribute to being simply
one of the most fun games to come out
this year yeah that about covers all of
it go get overwatch we'll be waiting for
you and thanks for watching subscribe to
our YouTube channel to watch more videos
at the one you just saw and leave a
comment to let us know which games you
think should have made the list